[Music]
glean maxwell
[Music]
oh his favorite what oh she's hot though
hey good titties
she exposed the list finally
i feel like we're the only news source
that talks of this but no one takes us
serious because because we talk about
her just because like yeah we could
object to fire yeah but we break so much
[ __ ] news that no one else does but
it's because we have so many dances on
the show everyone doesn't take this
seriously
that's not a dancer no if i was a judge
i'd like tell me who the [ __ ] on your
list unless you show me your titties
unless you show me your duties maybe
that's how she got out of it she's
probably getting out by showing titties
those are innocent titties it depends
though because if the bigger her nipples
the more i'll forget
really you don't like big nipples i'm
i'm super that's what i just said oh
okay okay like it's so good the bigger
the area it better take it all over his
office yeah yeah like most of the
breasts the whole [ __ ] thing it goes
down to her belly button yeah whoa
that's crazy it better look like a
goddamn birthmark
like breasts better be the accessory to
nipple yeah that's a salami i just
wanted to see not much breast i don't
want to see a lot of diplo that's a
baloney
well hopefully
it's it's not just a bologna it's like
a series of bologna we're looking at for
it to be like the funnel of like an oil
change for a car you know what i mean
we're looking at a bologna takeover you
know what i'm saying
like we're looking for angular wise i'll
give it a shot i don't know i don't want
a king shame but i'll give it a shot
yeah you didn't see it right there just
comes this way and then just google it
see if he likes very square there
so glenn was sentenced to uh 20 years
right 20 years in prison
that's it man but our kelly got 30. our
fellow got 30. but let's be real i love
the comparisons constantly i'm also uh
i'm opposed to her getting 20 though
what what do you think would be
necessary for her how many years she
needs to [ __ ] walk of life and then
give the whole list of who the [ __ ]
she's
who her customers were but dick elaine
pee on any kids
we don't know what she did honestly i
don't know she probably did good shot
okay she probably did it
she [ __ ] on some you [ __ ] massaged
on something probably peed and [ __ ] on
some my bad i don't take her for a peer
but a farter i do you think so she
probably sat on someone's lap and
[ __ ] laid a big one you think so yeah
wait what's a poetic justice for her
then
death by gas oh hey that is actually
foreign
do you think she should be like
trafficked around to a couple countries
first
she would like that's i like that i like
she would like it you know why i think
that
she blew george clooney
oh yeah that was the [ __ ] george
clooney's dick
that's true because at that point is it
like a favor to them or more so for you
i don't know because you're sucking a
celebrity's dick so it's like now that's
like something you took well there's
celebrities and there's george clooney
yeah
he's got great tequila he's a [ __ ]
daniel
fool's hot as [ __ ] what's your favorite
george clooney movie three kings three
kings is sick as [ __ ] oh my god i like
the descendants you're wrong ocean's 11.
you know what's right something good for
george clooney tomorrowland i thought it
was gonna be wack it was really
interesting oh yeah oh really yeah it
was written
as [ __ ] no it's whack but it's like
randomly interesting it was like it was
like robin williams's toys movie wow how
about up in the air
oh often the airstrike yeah you remember
the movie toys with like he's wearing a
red hat he's got a [ __ ] hole in there
some [ __ ]
like robin williams movie is [ __ ] up
as [ __ ] it was weird yeah i remember him
look it up i gotta see what the [ __ ] is
this i don't understand the reference
it's not a doctor-something movie i need
it too she really blew george clooney
yeah she sucked his dick i have no
[ __ ] clue what this movie is oh that
yes i haven't watched it isn't he out of
her
age range george clooney yeah like he's
like actually too old yeah she likes the
young actually an adult apparently she
did it out of obligation oh really so it
is she a slurper or is she a deep throat
what's the obligation in the article
okay
what's the obligation she had to do it
that's that's for the ring obligation
wait for for for the she said for the
sex ring i was [ __ ] trafficked into
his [ __ ] dick no no she was saying
like she was she had to do it because
like he's george clooney's so [ __ ]
hot he's a billionaire oh that's the
reason is her list coming out ever or
not the the politician and celebrity
what's his name what's this ufc fighter
who said that is he out of sonia sick
guy yeah that was a good question i hope
every by the way it should be a meme now
because remember when when we all were
doing like the uh epstein didn't kill
himself yeah i mean and it was like in
everything show us the list yeah show us
the list should be in everything it
should be in every interview everything
let's go explain the list not that it
helped to do the first thing but dude i
want to [ __ ] see it everywhere like i
want a [ __ ] news reporter to cover a
fire and then someone comes out and
describes the fire and then be like show
us the list the fire was like a crazy
show
yeah like like it's uh like peter or
some [ __ ] where they're trying to like
sneak into different establishments and
like [ __ ] run into the court and like
show a [ __ ] sign show us the list
dude i'll be seeing you should get a
tattoo of it across his chest i think
that'd go pretty far he never takes off
his shirt maybe my first tattoo ever
across your throat
there it is let's start the hashtag show
us the list
show us the list that's a good idea
actually yeah i think that's how jk goes
viral on every single
here's what's gonna happen
we all know
not to brag we're probably going to win
the streaming
for this one yeah no not for this one
but for a couple for many times we have
some hot contenders we got some we got a
lot of videos in the running yeah yeah
yeah we've done it we get up on stage
show us the list
yeah that's all we say thank you very
much show us the list
[ __ ] good right i want a local news
channel to cover a [ __ ] petting zoo
right and a kid's talking about [ __ ]
goats and they're like show us the list
the ghost says it yeah
it eats a [ __ ] can it's really good
it's good damn i can't believe [ __ ]
delaney just sucked george
sucked him off and she loved it you
think she's a double hander
huh yeah that's what i think it depends
on the dick that's what george said in
the article that says she's definitely
double handed
i wonder what george clooney has to say
about all this he said it was a weak
[ __ ]
he's more of a triple hander guy too
much teeth he said chris o'donnell
sucked him way better
robin
you uncultured swan you gonna google
that too yeah
what is wrong with you i'm just not i'm
not as old as you are he was just born
though that's
he's probably literally barely born
oh this dude's fat now what what else
did chris o'donnell do he did the george
clooney's dick dude what the [ __ ] the
cop show ncis
oh he did yeah he's on there huh i don't
know i watch football i see commercials
oh [ __ ] that's crystal dog you know what
blows my mind though is like okay elaine
maxwell so the whole epstein maxwell
situation right how many [ __ ] people
are tied to this to where both the right
and the left don't want to talk about it
they don't democrats and republicans
don't want to talk about it that's
around all the news sources don't want
to talk or american celebrities it took
a [ __ ] new zealand celebrity to talk
about it yeah like no [ __ ] celebrity
nobody wants it should be the number one
topic honestly and it's
mind-blowing that the johnny depp trial
was [ __ ] televised but not that was
really entertaining though yeah it was
but the judge sealed all the records
thank god for galen thank god but why
exactly to protect the [ __ ] people
who actually were doing this this sounds
like a national [ __ ] case where the
whole [ __ ] world
should see it a uk prime minister his
name is lord british he was he was
[ __ ] kids and they covered it up over
there he actually gets convicted
part of a pedophile ring this was all
talked about for like 30 years everyone
saw us all conspiracy [ __ ] and now
here we are yeah it's wild the same size
but but people are like oh i still can't
talk about it yet wait people were
talking about this guy doing that for
like 30 years people were talking about
doing it for 30 years including the
catholic church so there was a
journalist um i think he was for
washington post or something like that
but he was on joe rogan he was this and
joel rogan was just asking like
why aren't journalists doing their job
and why aren't they just [ __ ] going
out there and saying like hey this is a
great [ __ ] story and he goes no there
actually are people but
a lot of journalists also know that
these things might get uh it might not
pass it might not get greenlit or
whatever so they don't even bother or
let's say someone is investigating doing
it and it gets all the way get to the it
goes to the top
but then it gets shut down by the by the
editor and then they go no no we're not
[ __ ] doing this or you get assanged
it's like hey um oh you're leaking
government secrets and all this [ __ ] and
you're oh you're getting our agents
killed in the field even though they can
never prove any of that stuff so it's
like oh okay well then the media just
reports on that and says like yeah sam's
a piece of [ __ ] he was getting spies
killed and all this stuff which assange
was like prove it you can't yeah i never
did anything
um where snowden actually even snowden
he's like yeah i didn't do any of that
but maybe you know when i was releasing
some of this stuff that could have
happened but joining us they couldn't
prove any of that but here we are he's
persecuted he's being
um
brought back to the united states
extradited he'll probably die in prison
we probably won't even blink when they
say the cameras were out and here we are
but what blows my mind is that he's not
even a u.s citizen so how can we
extradite
non-us citizens because he committed a
crime against our government my friend
and nobody's allowed he spilled the
beans on us he was whistleblower
they always love to say how important it
is to have a whistleblower but how can
you be a traitor if you're not even a us
citizen
but they but they love to to play up the
whistleblower thing but then when a
whistleblower happens
against the government they can't wait
to [ __ ] on them it's weird so is uh
glenn going to
in jail yeah how long do you think she
has do you think she ends up dead i
think she said some interesting stuff
like she recently came out and said like
yo i was helping the clinton foundation
quite a bit with a lot of stuff going on
and to me that was like yo you better
not kill me [ __ ]
i know [ __ ]
but then wouldn't that be reason to kill
her more like she's no [ __ ] yeah if i'm
team clinton i'm [ __ ] looking oh no
man pay off some guards the thing that
kills me the most is i don't want to
[ __ ] wait 40 years to find out what
happened
because that we're eventually going to
find out like there's going to be we
don't even know about the jfk like jfk
they keep delaying that and you know why
they do it though
sources and methods are going to get all
[ __ ] up if we released it all [ __ ]
up yeah okay from the 60s bro you still
got people in the bureau from the 60s
dude
it's a joke
it was the mafia our government is a
joke we're never going to find out
how how do you trust anything anybody
says here i don't get it that's what you
only trust us because we're the ones
asking for that i trust just kidding
news yeah i do your number one news
source for the truth [ __ ] your mom or
your dad yep asking the real questions
and why if you woke up blindfolded and
you're tied up and your mom
you're in your side of your mom but your
dad is behind you do you go forward or
you go backwards oh
the teeter totter do you have morning
wood
you have to pick one brought to you by
upstart
it feels bad so you need a loan but you
also need to [ __ ] your mom or your dad
you